herzlich willkommen zur zweiten folge
von 1 tag als persönlicher koch beim
letzten mal war jan von gewitter im kopf
zu gast und ich konnte ihn mit 30 von 30
punkten von meinen kochkünsten
überzeugen
heute ist regel dran und wie jan beim
letzten mal gesagt hat
hier werden wir mal sehen ich würde
sagen wir fangen an mit dem frühstück
let's go wir sind angekommen wir kennen
quasi schon das setup es ist nämlich gar
nicht mal so anders als das was ich
letzte woche für jan gemacht habe es
gibt wieder benedikt
nur diesmal mit lachs und du wirst mit
halloumi essen ich hoffe dass wir wegen
dieses gerät anfangen käse aber das
gleiche aber dann nehmen wir den besten
ich habe nämlich kein hallo wie geht's
los ist aber ich lese da genauso gemacht
aber so schon jetzt erstmal ist habe ich
den schweren tagen dazu sagen rede
ernährt sich vegetarisch das heißt heute
wird es noch nie gegeben okay weil es
wie gesagt der geräte gibt habe ich
draußen schon mal den grill angeworfen
das wird ein baum wirklich vom grill und
nicht kann oder so ähnlich muss auch
sagen was mich eine sehr schöne küche
dass wir zusammenarbeiten
kennt ihr ja schon vom letzten mal ich
habe mal zwei drei mal ein glaube ich
brauche ein traum ist es so ein vierter
was man nicht so normalerweise zum
frühstück alles macht 1 hier sind jetzt
die brötchen am teuersten ist das alles
nach plan und gucken wie gut
funktioniert strudel machen
und ich lege jetzt einfach mal den boden
von den brötchen ist er mit avocado aus
ich werde das ganze so in zwei hälften
die seinen der anbau und die anderen
mitgerissen da kann man sich das so
schön zusammenlegen und jetzt schon ganz
vorsichtig den sondern dessen oder ihre
leute sieht einfach echt zu schüren und
das schnappen hatten also kein problem
das karree wie hier mit harry barbecue
grill asse passiert ist
du siehst es ist wirklich sehr fein
staratschek pochiert aber ich danke es
ja ich würde sagen dass mich so
schmecken
wir sehen dass wir die einnahmen sind
leider nicht perfekt passiert sie haben
sich trotzdem sorgen ja mag es gerne
auch so wie du musst wissen für jedes
essen was sie heute kochen müssen wir
später eine bewertung geben auch sie
sehen das heißt das im hinterkopf werden
wir essen und lass dir schmecken nicht
nur schmecken da bringt ja ja finde ich
immer gerne vom grill gemacht was ich
finde es richtig ist schrecklich aber
gut wird kann er also das muss ein guter
koch nicht berücksichtigten aber ich
hätte ehrlich aok davon grübels die
verschwendung welche dann ruiniert die
so ihr wunsch sind ist unschuldiges
aroma ja
ein bisschen kannst du schon mal selbst
gemachten mitschnitt sei allerdings noch
nicht dass wir noch mal tüchtig habt ja
du kannst bis zu zehn punkte von jedem
zehnten das perfekte ex lehrer das
perfekte frühstück gewesen also ich bin
ja das ist ja gut und ein bisschen
kritik haben sie sich anzuhören
es war sehr sehr lecker das war perfekt
aber die sofort an der zwar nicht mal
nein
die war nicht kommt es durch gewährt
leider da gibt es ein paar abzüge
das projekt war super allerdings in drin
haben wir laufen müssen weiter und ich
hätte die avocado gern gewinnt gehabt
aber ich würde sagen es sind trotzdem
sowie den sieben von zehn punkten sehr
gut ich habe ein bisschen zufrieden
daher bin ich zufrieden
jan von mir wird darüber hatten wir
letztes mal für alle szenen gegeben aber
revier hat auf jeden fall ihr merkt es
einen höheren anspruch das ist umso
besser für mich selbst denn ich werde
die bei dem mittag und abendessen
komplett überzeugen ich sozusagen let's
go direkt zum mittagessen ist ist
relativ basic ihr seht schon gern rucola
wir haben eine richtig fette
wassermelone bisschen brot regieren sich
einen buzzer millionen väter salat
gewünscht dann wenn nämlich auch noch
eine spazierfahrt wir sind sie schon
wieder vermengen die stadt für sich ein
büro das heißt ich werde einfach super
viel machen die freezers und den
richtern auf der alle was mit alle für
ein essen macht das ein guter
persönlicher kopf ich weiß wenn ich auf
jeden fall ein paar tipps gekauft als
erstes müssen wir buchen abschneiden und
waschen schneiden wer einmal die
strümpfe also die kann man habe ich mit
essen aber wenn man das jetzt ist eh zu
spät ich habe das alles frisch und was
ja was einem türkischen supermarkt
normalerweise hat man das nicht drin
rucola
dieser salat
da ist so einfach es gehört eigentlich
verboten
[Musik]
scheiße jetzt schneiden wir die
wassermelonen ich habe mir dazu
vorgestellt dass sie das vielleicht
schafft hier so anschneidet und sagen da
an die ganzen kerne so im zentrum
rankommt müssen wir versuchen da wird
probiert gerne zumindest rauszunehmen
muss man ja die unbedingt in salat haben
die wasserlose entkernen sich wer das
jetzt einfach so ungefähr gleich große
stücke schneiden konnten unterlagen die
bauten ein ansonsten gibt es ja ich gar
nicht viel zu erzählen das ist
eigentlich echt super danke basis essen
für mich als persönlicher kopp man muss
einfach noch ein bisschen olivenöl dazu
machen ganz klein bisschen klimadebatte
spur dazu ansonsten ist das wirklich
einfach nicht schwer ich radio oder in
diese barcelona jetzt mal schnell die
täter fertig für diejenigen die sich
nicht vegan er
wir müssen eigentlich hätte ein malteser
probieren was uns im datacenter fest
richtig es ist ein guter ist eine gute
alternative zum besten was ist der beste
rewe bio ich bin fitter werden wir
vielleicht aber separat auch machen dass
die väter separat erhältlich auch so
macht nicht nur bei auch leute mit essen
die veganen sind dass sie daran einfach
auf menschen vermischt ist mit der
arbeit und nicht nur das ganze wie kann
ich das schlauer machen
200 von dave und ried jährlich sofres
hallo mein bester text vorab in dem mit
medizin interne rhein sind jetzt
eigentlich konstant band das sollte
reichen leid angelastet die pid kann
davon ist eben nicht und wir sind gleich
bei baby
ich habe gerade schon gesehen was sie
angerichtet haben
economiesuisse wurde wie ein riese und
hatte dabei ist kann nicht mehr gerät
mit diesem artikel ab es ist deshalb zum
großen teil veganen nur wie gesagt ich
extra gemacht
was hat euch sagen lasst es uns
schmecken und du denkst wieder daran
nicht gleich zu bewerten wir hoffentlich
war es ihr erster weltkrieg so doch nur
was ein riesenkampf ablehne so ein
anderer schwerpunkt hat plötzlich kommt
nun pick und gut ist einfach ich glaube
da steige jetzt außer kontext vor dem
görlitzer ihr geschmeckt doch richtig
gut geschmeckt positiv rechnung zu
machen ist er ja und ich nehme mir das
belegt nicht rationiert würde nicht nur
zehn prozent geben aber einfach ein
bisschen verwirrt und da muss ich wieder
kritisch sein mag sein ja auch gerne und
ich habe sie belogen kerle mit vielen
tempowechseln nach nicht immer belohnt
könig gesagt ich hab wirklich in diesem
video später nachschauen ich habe
probiert die melodik daraus zu machen
ist eigentlich die kritik ist sie nicht
man kann nie sicher sein kann ich
erwachsen einem lohn im bauch wächst
mit neuen konzepten
damit gehe ich nicht selbst wenn dich
jetzt einen aufsteiger zu zehnt da wird
sie dazu finanziell richtig einstellt
auch tradition cockpit 10 euro an
ok dann sehen uns beim abendessen die
bissstelle das wird einen auflauf geben
und zwar mit aubergine liberté vom
gasgrill grillen aber ich würde sagen
wir fangen einfach schritt für schritt
an setzten erst mal der fall und ein
topf auf den herd wenig fahne kommt
erstmal eine gute menge oliven will man
kann eigentlich nicht genug kunden
gehören canale reichert ehre das setzen
wir schön heiß werden
der zwischenzeit ich hab mir schon einen
start nächste vorbereitet hat mir hier
ein
geschälte tomaten nicht gehackten
tomaten geschehen doch weil wir selbst
fachen der
sehr gut rein schönen oder auch sehr
einfach für den geschmack und kann eben
mal ganz gut andrücken weil dann
entfernt diese haut wie von selbst kann
ich euch noch empfehlen und reggae hat
sie sich noch gewünscht für den auflauf
das werde ich später dazu geben einen
vegetarischen fleischersatz dass sie
jetzt grün entschieden fand ich hatte
ganz gut gepasst in der aubergine glaube
es gibt sehr viele leute die meine
technik bekommen so kritisiert werden so
das geht nicht ist die aubergine wir
haben einfach mal das abgrund das ende
und schneiden das ganze jetzt in circa
rheinhallen zentimeter dicke scheiben
die überwiegend geschnitten
ich schmeiße jetzt also kurz die das
polster auf dem balkon sehr gut kennt
worte das ist sehr gut begegnen ist
einfach die tomaten hinein sollten heißt
es heute mit einer und wieso daran mache
das ganze auf die neisser dass noch
andere leute dabei sind bei ich mache
dieses format wäre ich eigentlich noch
so gut dass ich liebend gerne für andere
leute um mich um andere leute kümmern
und sogar noch mehr erwartet und das
ganze hier ist schon am vor sich hin
können das ist sehr guten gewandt
bisschen jetzt darunter jetzt regt zur
ultra kraft thematik ist es ehrlich
nicht mehr normal wir geben dazu wird
noch ein bisschen frischem basilikum
dieser art tomatensoße zu machen also
mit den ganzen tomatenmark uns wirklich
glaube ich ein kleiner geheimtipp so das
ganze auch nicht zu stark hier an ich
bin auf jeden fall erstmal komplett
runter mit der hitze freuen wäre das
hier weiter kocht wirklich noch mal raus
auf die hand gehen zum gas
kerntemperatur nicht wundern dass wir
hier so ein bisschen staubig ist es dann
natürlich sauber
die stehen jetzt ein bisschen ihre zeit
haben
während das hier vor sich hin tötet und
draußen berlin auf dem gelände einfach
wenn man den käse nicht leicht brauchte
reid bzw schneiden ist es noch zwei
parteien schneiden die scheiben und
zwischendurch auch die überwiegend immer
gewendet wie gesagt es wird ein bisschen
viele aber knapp die gesamten 500 gramm
hinein
die haben jetzt eine kochzeit von elf
minuten da das ganze nochmal in den ofen
kommt würde ich sorgen machen wir darauf
achten wir haben nicht schön gegrillte
auberginen und die werden jetzt fein
schneiden sind kleine streifen falls ihr
euch fragt warum haben wir das gemacht
das grillen ganz einfach man kriegt
übels die geilen aromen einfach daraus
wenn man das ganze hier auf dem grill
zubereitet ich meine das jetzt einfach
schön runter und so kleine streifen so
darf kommen wir jetzt hier hinein zur
tomate bisschen pfeffer das ganze
palette kurz den fleischersatz anbraten
und ich schreibe schon mal ein paar
meter neben mir gleich brauchen ich
schulde die nudeln ab und geht direkt
rein
ja sie sehr sehr schön uci ich hatte ein
bisschen schiss sind vielleicht zu wenig
format angespart haben aber das scheint
nicht der fall zu sein
über mit fertig jetzt nehmen wir einfach
hiervon so schön passt da ein wenig und
legen den boden auch von der auswahl von
sehr gut ist mir noch so und zumba
choreo kommt natürlich noch ein bisschen
büffelmozzarella lassen uns nicht lumpen
und tag würde ich die drei übrigens
meine bachelorarbeit note zurückbekommt
mit einem 7 und ich bin jetzt bachelor
ich habe mein studium bestanden
einzelnen chat oder so
hallo re die man lieber was ich befinde
mich in den allerletzten vorkehrungen
schicke jetzt gleich den traumhaften
auflauf deines lebens in den backofen
für 20 minuten und komme dann muss so
nächste lage der schönen mozzarella
denn ungefähr drei lagen seien gespannt
wie sich der fleisch ersatz vom hähnchen
darin macht uns überrascht mich erstmal
wieder drin viel in so einer auflaufform
reingeht wirklich sehr gut dass ganzes
randvoll und wir hoffen dass jetzt mit
jeder menge kann mir sagen also ihr seht
ihn von sich reden es ist kein spaß
alles klar da wir das ganze ab in den
ofen für 20 minuten und dann auf dem weg
zur abbey vergleicht das an das bewusst
die leute uns liegt bei dem sucht hast
genüge oft gut gesättigt tatsächlich
also meine ernährung sollte die ist sehr
gut optik sehr orange täglich fahren
grüner zeit hätten sicherlich nicht
geschadet
naja großen und ganzen ist es auf jeden
fall sehr ansprechend ok dann würde ich
sagen dass dir schmecken wird vom
gleichen wertung wieder und auch
gegessen so wird es den ganzen tag über
von mir bekommt was ist ein pc mit dem
die medizin irgendwie okay wir haben das
mögliche klage von sieben beim traffic
auf 984 dann sehen wir heute die
kommentare schreiben wurde es auch
machen so ist wo soll ich das auch
machen
dieter bohlen zum beispiel wenn die da
noch so weiß ich nicht
oder machen